now for the latest on what's happening
in China that's joined Katrina you in
Beijing some slightly better news out of
China no new local transmissions of the
virus reported there yes that's quite a
milestone as you mentioned zero
homegrown cases not only across the
country but in Hubei Province which is
the epicenter of the outbreak where this
all started we have to remember that at
that eighty thousand people have been
infected in China they have been three
thousand deaths
mostly in Hubei Province mostly in Wuhan
City so it has zero new cases is indeed
extraordinary and at this peak of this
outbreak in February we had hundreds of
new cases every day we had thousands of
doctors and nurses flown in from all
over the country to help treat these
patients while now those medical
personnel have been allowed to return to
their home cities their home provinces
and 16 temporary hospitals that were
opened to deal with this case so they've
now been closed also what we're hearing
is that 11 provinces in China have
announced that they're going to reopen
schools soon though that's very big at
the end of March or April they're going
to reopen high schools and primary
schools so that's also very significant
news but at the same time China is not
out of the woods yet there have been 34
new cases in the country announced in
the past 24 hours and those have all
been imported cases so for China this is
a very big concern there are concerns
and among the public that there could be
a second wave of new infections from
people bringing the virus back from
other countries to China and we've just
heard that Beijing Airport is deciding
to redirect some flights coming in to
Beijing to other airports so that people
can be processed now their temperatures
checks etc before they can even fly into
the capital now 21 of these new cases
are in Beijing and that's because
Beijing receives the most international
travelers I think in one day they have
more than 5,000 travelers flying into
the capital every day so they've been
starting to step up some of these travel
restrictions if you come to Beijing you
must head into a designated quarantine
hospital at your own expense they're
very serious criminal
if you seem to be trying to circumvent
these restrictions or if you seem to be
concealing any symptoms so it still
remains a big challenge for China and I
think definitely although we've had the
good news with these zero new cases
they're still a long way yet before
China can comfortably say that this
outbreak is over here al-jazeera's
Katrina you reporting live from Beijing
many thanks indeed Katrina